हेलो गैस वेलकम तू आर युटुब चैनल डिक्शनरी
का डेट 6 तो आपको ऑलरेडी पता है की लेक्चर
वन से लेकर लेक्चर फाइव से अपलोड हो चुका
है ऑलरेडी अब हमारी युटुब चैनल पर ए के
यहां वीडियो सेशन में देख सकते हैं
यहां तक रिस्पांस ठीक रहा है और मैं
उम्मीद करता हूं की जितनी भी चीज समझे है
जितने भी लेक्चर मैंने जितने मतलब टास्क
दिया था मैंने वो सब अपने कंप्लीट किया
होंगे अगर नहीं कंप्लीट किया हैं तो आपको
कंप्लीट कर लेना है पहले इसके बाद ही आपको
ये वीडियो समझ में आएगी वरना ये वीडियो
फॉलो करने में मतलब नहीं रहेगा ठीक है ना
तो उम्मीद करता हूं मैं आपकी पहले आपको
पांच लेक्चर कंप्लीट कर लेंगे पुरी तरीके
से प्रैक्टिस के साथ और इसके बाद ये अब जो
है आगे बढ़ेंगे क्योंकि प्रैक्टिस साड़ी
चीज चल रही है
तो आपको सब कुछ प्रैक्टिस करते चलना आएगा
ना दिक्कत हो जाएगी ठीक है इसके अलावा आप
हमारे पेज पे ए सकते हैं यहां पर आपको
फॉलो कर लेना है हमारे पेज को और जो भी आप
पोस्ट होती है जैसे जो भी यहां पर लेक्चर
आएगा उसके यहां पर पोस्ट आपको मिल जाएगी
तो उसे पोस्ट को कमेंट करना है की आपको
कैसा लगा लेक्चर आपको कोई फीडबैक है तो वो
आप देख सकते हैं और आप उसको शेर भी कर
सकते हैं ठीक है इससे आपको कोई फायदा है
हमारा भी फायदा है ठीक है नागरिक होगी
आपके लिए और कैंडिडेट ला पाएंगे तो उम्मीद
करता हूं की वो टास्क भी आप अपना कर लेंगे
पूरा अच्छे तरीके से बट रहा है की आप जो
भी है शेर भी कर सकते हैं अगर कोई रूम
कंप्लीट करते हैं हमारे साथ तो उसको आप
शेर कर सकते हैं टैग करते हुए ठीक है तो
चलिए शुरू करते हैं आज के लेक्चर में
ट्राई करें पहले और यहां पर आपको मॉडल्स
में ए जाना है हम नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी वाला
मोडल कर रहे थे तो इसमें ए जाता हूं मैं
इसमें ऑलरेडी हमने पैसे रिकॉन्सिलियस कर
लिया है तो अब तक हमने टोटल इसमें जो
नेटवर्क फंडामेंटल्स थे पहले वो हमने
कंप्लीट किया सर जितना इसमें था वो और
उसके साथ जो एक्स्ट्रा चीज जरूर थी वो
मैंने आपको बताया ठीक है इसके बाद अब हमने
पैसे यहां पर किया अब हम एक्टिव रिकमेंड
देखने जा रहे हैं ठीक है ना तो इसको ओपन
कर लेट हूं मैं इसके बाद हमने आज इतनी चीज
साड़ी चीज करके साड़ी करेंगे और एक्स्ट्रा
ज्यादा जरूर होगी मैं आपको करते रहूंगा
ठीक है प्रैक्टिकल भी ना करूंगा एक्स्ट्रा
जो इसमें दे दिया है वो भी ज्यादा क्योंकि
वो हम लोग इंक्लूड कर देंगे ठीक है तो अभी
मैं एक्टिविटी कौन से वाला ओपन कर लेट हूं
ये रूम
यहां पर टेक्स्ट बॉक्स को स्टार्ट करते
हैं अभी से क्योंकि मेरे ख्याल से इसकी
जरूर पढ़ने वाली है
पहले बात हमने की थी कौन सा क्या होता है
अब 1 मिनट लीजिए और अपने से रिवाइज कीजिए
तो मैं बताता हूं वापस से ये कॉन्सेप्ट था
आपका की आप इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग कर रहे थे
अपने टारगेट के बड़े में ठीक है इनफॉरमेशन
को गदर कर रहे थे आप तो उसके लिए हमने दो
तरीका पढ़ा था पैसे भी कौन सा और एक्टिव
रिक्रूटो मैंने आपको बताया था की पैसे भी
कॉन्शांइस का मतलब ये होता है की आपका जो
टारगेट है आप उससे डायरेक्टली इंटरेक्ट
नहीं कर रहे हैं ठीक है अब इनडायरेक्ट
किसी तरीके से जो पब्लिकली अवेलेबल
इनफॉरमेशन है ऐसे पब्लिक उतनी पब्लिक नहीं
भी है लेकिन वो आप डायरेक्ट टारगेट्स नहीं
ले रहे हैं ठीक है ये टारगेट से रिलेटेड
ऐसे नहीं ले रहे हैं तो वो आपके पैसे
रिकॉग्निशन में आएगा और अगर आप अपने
टारगेट को डायरेक्टली टारगेट से इंगेज हो
रहे हैं डायरेक्टली उससे इंटरेक्ट कर रहे
हैं तो वो आपके जो है एक्टिव में ए जाएगा
जैसे एग्जांपल मैंने आपको बताया था तीन कर
तू इस तरीके का है लास्ट लेक्चर में बताया
था मैंने आपको तो क्लियर ही होगा आपको एक
एग्जांपल मैं आपको और देता हूं एक्टिवेट
पैसे यहां पे सामने दिया हुआ है की आप
किसी मतलब एनीमी की टेरिटरी है आप उसको
दूर से दूरबीन से देख रहे हैं तो आपके
पैसे कौन थे ठीक है और आप वहां जाकर उसका
जो है अच्छे से पूरा इंटरेस्टिंग देख रहे
हैं तो वो आपका एक्टिव कॉन्सेप्ट में ए
जाएगा ठीक है इसको टेक्निकल टर्म में बात
करें तो आप का सकते हैं जैसे आपका राइट का
पेज विजिट कर रहे हैं और उसमें से कोई
मतलब ऐसा इंटरेक्शन करके वहां से
इनफॉरमेशन निकाल रहे हैं तो वो आपके थोड़ा
कन्फ्यूजन में ए जाएगा लेकिन अगर आप ऊपर
से कुछ कर रहे हैं तो आपके पास में आएगा
ठीक है
चलिए तो क्या बात करने
से पिंक के बड़े में टैबलेट के बड़े में
और नेट के बड़े में समझना वाले हैं इस रूम
के जारी और जरूर होगी आपको अब सोचेंगे हो
सकता है की ये कर चीज तो बहुत छोटी है
अपने मतलब बेसिकली इसको उसे किया होगा
आपने पिंक और नहीं उसे करता है अपने उसे
किया ऊपर वो भी मुस्लिम लोगों उसे किया
हुआ है टेंडर भी सुना होगा आप लोगों ने
एक-एक लाइन की कमांड है इसमें फिर मतलब
क्या इतना लंबा चलेगा तो ऐसा नहीं है इसके
बड़े में थोड़ा दीप में जाएंगे अच्छे से
और समथिंग की जो आता है वो क्या होता है
उसमें एक-एक टर्म को समझेंगे हम लोग और
बढ़िया समझेंगे उसे चीज को इसकी जरूर है
लिटरली है ठीक है सिर्फ डेफिनेशन पॉइंट ऑफ
व्यू से नहीं है मतलब उसकी जरूर
प्रैक्टिकल लेवल पे है तो इसलिए हम उसको
अच्छे से समझेंगे ठीक है ना तो आगे बढ़ता
हूं मैं
इसको पहले फिर स्क्रीन कर लेते हैं
ओके
चलिए तो वही दिया हुआ है डेफिनेशन दिया
हुआ है
इसमें कुछ खास है नहीं इसको हम लोगों की
कर लेते हैं यहां पर वो चीज लिखी हुई है
की अगर
ये ये रहा अगर आप सब्सक्राइब नहीं मतलब
अगर आपका अकाउंट जो है वो प्रीमियम वाला
अकाउंट नहीं है ट्राई टेक्निक पे तो अटैक
बॉक्स से आपका कम नहीं बनेगा क्योंकि ये
टैग बॉक्स में इंटरनेट एक्सेस नहीं मिलता
है आपको फ्री वाले पे ठीक है तो या तो अगर
आपके पास प्रीमियम है तो तू ठीक है अटैक
बॉक्स ओपन कर लीजिए और प्रीमियम नहीं है
अगर आप तो एमवेयर थे आप कईयों से
डायरेक्टली ओपन अप शुरू कनेक्ट कर दीजिए
ठीक है वो आपको पता ही होगा उसमें दिक्कत
नहीं हनी चाहिए और बाकी मैं उम्मीद करता
हूं की आप लोगों को मेरे साथ करते होंगे
जो भी रूम मतलब करने लायक है वो आप साथ
में फॉलो करते होंगे नहीं तो वीडियो देखने
के बाद करते होंगे पॉज करके आप आंसर जरूर
सोचिएगा हमेशा ठीक है ये हमेशा से कहता
हूं आपको कोई आंसर जो मैं करने जाऊंगा
उसमें तो उसके पहले वीडियो पॉज करिए और
फिर सोचिए आंसर क्या हो सकता है ठीक है
चलिए
आगे बढ़ते हैं पहले बात करते हैं वेब
ब्राउज़र की ठीक है अब हम लोग एक्टिविटी
कॉन्शांइस करने जा रहे हैं
एक्टिवली जैसे आपको पता ही है की जब आप
ब्राउज़र कनेक्ट करते हैं मतलब जैसे मैंने
आपको बताया था ऑलरेडी की यहां पर आकर आप
मां लीजिए google.com लिखने हैं ठीक है तो
आपने क्या लिखा है यहां पर google.com ये
क्या है ये डोमेन है इसको ठीक है मैं इंटर
करता हूं यहां पर गूगल खुला गया तो ये
क्या है
आपने क्या दिया है आपने सिर्फ यहां पर एक
दो में नाम दिया ठीक है ना लेकिन अगर क्या
करना लगा के यहां पर लिखना हूं 443 और
इंटर करता हूं तो भी ओपन हो रहा है लेकिन
अगर यही पर कुछ और लिख देता हूं जैसे मां
लीजिए 8000
यहां पर लोडिंग करता रहेगा और यहां पर ओपन
नहीं होगा ठीक है ना क्योंकि आपको फोटो
कौन से पता ही है मैंने आपको पूरे को
सॉकेट कहते हैं ठीक है डोमेन नाम ट्रॉली
लगाके आप पोर्ट नहीं लिखने हैं जी पोर्ट
पे आपको जो सर्विस रन हो रही है उसका करना
है उसका फोटो लिखने हैं यहां पर तो
डिफॉल्ट बाय डिफॉल्ट ब्राउज़र क्या करता
है क्योंकि बाय डिफॉल्टर स्टैंडर्ड पोर्ट
है 84 पोर्ट नंबर 80 आपके एचडीबी के लिए
है पोर्ट नंबर 443 आपके एसटीडीपीएस के लिए
है ठीक है तो अगर आप कोई भी एड्रेस यहां
लिखने हैं तो बाय डिफॉल्ट अगर आपने
एचटीटीपी लिखा है ठीक है एचडीएफसी नहीं
लिखा है तो वो टट्टी लगा और अगर आपने
एचटीटीपीएस लिखा है तो पोर्ट 443 लगा अगर
आपने एचटीटीपी कुछ नहीं लिखा है तो बाय
डिफॉल्टर फ्री ट्राई करेगा पहले ठीक है तो
जैसे यहां पर 1 मिनट को हम लिखने हैं
हमारे लिए तो भी वही चीज आप इंटर करेंगे
तो ओपन हो जाएगा लेकिन इसका मतलब ये है की
अपने पोर्ट और 43 पे ओपन किया है इस चीज
को यहां पर भी करके दिखता हूं आपको मैं
देखिए से ही चीज ओपन हो गया ठीक है ना तो
अगर आपका वेबसाइट
हो रहा है तो आप इस तरीके से ओपन कर सकते
हैं लेकिन आपको इस पर साइन करना पड़ेगा
जिसने आपको दिखता हूं यहां पर मेरे यहां
पर विंडो
मिलता हूं पाइथन से मैं एचडी टीवी सर्विस
चालू कर रहा हूं ठीक है ये मैंने आपको
बताया हुआ है
ठीक है तो मुझे क्या करना है अभी मेरे को
पोर्ट 8000 खोलना है तो मैं लिखूंगा सिंपल
8000 पर ठीक है
करना पड़ेगा अगर डिफॉल्ट पोर्ट नहीं है तो
बेसिक सी बात है पता ही होगी अगर लेकिन
अगर नहीं पता है तो फिर भी कोशिश करते हैं
की सबको क्लियर एकदम इसीलिए मैंने ये भी
एक बार बता दिया आपको चलिए रिक्वेस्ट करिए
सर ठीक है यहां पर आपने नोटिफिकेशन क्या
हुआ ये चीज ये गेट रिक्वेस्ट का फॉर्मेट
है ठीक है तो उसके बड़े में अभी आगे बात
करेंगे थोड़ा सा फिलहाल मैं क्लोज कर देता
हूं
चलिए यहां पर वही चीज दिया हुआ है की आप
डायरेक्टली अपनी टारगेट मतलब जो भी आप
टारगेट है उसकी वेबसाइट अगर है कंपनी अगर
आपको टारगेट है ईटिकली ठीक है तब की
वेबसाइट को ओपन करके वहां से जो है
इंफेक्शन कर सकते हैं जैसे यहां पर हम लोग
फायरफॉक्स उसे करते हैं इसके लिए
ऑफर देता हूं मैं इस मां लीजिए हम लोग
अपनी वेबसाइट पे ए जाते हैं
चलिए मैंने यहां पर अपनी वेबसाइट खोल ली
है ठीक है मतलब हमारी वेबसाइट यहां पर अब
मैं इसमें कोई पल जाता हूं मैं वेरीफाई
अथॉरिटी या सर्विसेज किसी पर जा सकता हूं
मैं यहां पर इस तरीके से कांसेज करूंगा
लेकिन कोई पेस्ट करके आपको दो-तीन ऑप्शन
क्या मिलता है एक तो आप डायरेक्टली मतलब
सर्व कीजिए ठीक है उसके बड़े में पढ़िए की
अगर यहां कितनी चीज लिखी हुई है उसको
समझिए अच्छे से इसके अलावा आप यहां पर
राइट क्लिक करेंगे तो आपको यहां पर
इंस्पेक्टर का ऑप्शन मिल जाता है ठीक है
व्यू प्ले स्टोर से आप इसका जो है फ्रंट
हैंड पे जो सूट है वो देख सकते हैं आप ठीक
है और यहां पर ए के इंस्पेक्टर में आप चेक
कर सकते हैं इसके बड़े में और चीज
फैसिलिटी मिल जाति है जैसे की आपका यहां
पर कंट्रोल है ठीक है ये अगर है नेटवर्क
है तो नेटवर्क से आप जो है नेटवर्क
ट्रैफिक देख सकते हैं दीप अगर से आप यहां
पर अपनी फाइल देख सकते हैं ठीक है gs5 इस
तरीके से बहुत साड़ी चीज यहां पर मिल जाति
है ठीक है ना यहां पर आप अपनी स्टोरी में
जाके प्लीज देख सकते हैं कौन सी जगह पर
स्टोर है उनमें चेंज कर सकते हैं तो इस
तरीके से काफी चीज आपको यहां मिलती है
इनमें से मेरा यहां पर इंस्पेक्टर हो जाता
है भाई जब यहां पर जो पेज है वो दिखता है
जैसे मां लीजिए आपको यहां पर सर्विस बटन
करना है तो इस पे लेक बताइए ये आपको पॉइंट
आउट कर देगा वहां पे ठीक है नेटवर्क में
रिक्वेस्ट करता हूं ये देखिए कितनी
रिक्वेस्ट हुई है आपके सामने दिखे जाएगी
तो ये भी एक काफी जरूरी इनफॉरमेशन हो
शक्ति है ठीक है ना अगर आप बना रहे हैं तो
आपको ये सब उसे करना पड़ता है हालांकि ये
कम तो क भी कर देता है और चीज आपको यहां
पर हेल्प हो जाएंगे ठीक है ना तो आगे
दिखता हूं मैं आपको यहां पर
चलिए ठीक है वही चीज दिया हुआ है
ठीक है तो उसने बहुत सारे मतलब एक्सटेंशन
आते हैं अगर आप सर्च करते हैं मतलब ये
फायरफॉक्स
एक्सटेंशंस ठीक है तो आपको बहुत सारे यहां
पर एक्सटेंशन मिल जाएंगे एक्सटेंशन स्टोर
में
रहेगा
ठीक है तो कुछ जरूरी है स्टेशन के बड़े
में यहां पर बताया गया है आपको तो इनमें
से एक जरूरी जो एक्सटेंशन है वो है फॉक्स
की प्रोक्सी जो की मैं यहां पर उसे कर रहा
हूं ठीक है ऑलरेडी उसे कर रहा हूं मैं
आपको दिखता हूं फॉक्सी प्रोक्सी के बड़े
में
पक्षी पक्षी यहां से आके आप यहां पर
इंस्टॉल कर सकते हैं मेरे ऑलरेडी इंस्टॉल
हो तो रिमूव करने को बोल रहा है इसका
फायदा ये होता है की आप यहां प्रोक्सी में
चेंज कर सकते हैं मतलब अगर आपने बर्फ सेट
किया हुआ है ऑलरेडी आपको पता होगा इसके
बड़े में ऑप्शन दिखता हूं क्योंकि यहां पर
आकर मैंने एड पे गया ठीक है एड पर जाकर
मैंने एक प्रोक्सी एड की प्रॉक्सिमिटी नाम
दाल दिया बर्फ एड्रेस दाल दिया ये ठीक है
और पूर्व भी दाल दिया दिखता हूं आपको ये
देखिए मतलब कोई भी ट्रैफिक इस रोटी हो
जाएगा और इस एड्रेस परमिशन कौन कर रहा
होगा ठीक है
जब ये ऑन होगा तो कनेक्ट होगा जब ये मैं
उसे नहीं कर रहा होगा तो सबसे कनेक्ट नहीं
होगा ठीक है इसका भी कर सकते हैं ये
बढ़िया आएगा तो ये डायरेक्टली तो इंफिनिटी
ज्यादा नहीं करता है आपके लिए
मतलब स्विच करने के लिए आप टर्न ऑफ कर
दीजिए बर्फ कर दीजिए चलेगा
क्या होता है जैसे मां लीजिए मैं कोई साइड
ओपन करता हूं अपनी साइड ओपन करता हूं
ओपन करता हूं मैं आता हूं ठीक है
कोई भी रिक्वेस्ट करेंगे
ठीक है रिक्वेस्ट है रिक्वेस्ट मिलेगा
यहां पर यूजर रिजल्ट
बताता है की जिसने रिक्वेस्ट किया है वो
किस टाइप का सिस्टम है तो यहां पर दिया
हुआ है की ये मोज़िला है विंडोज का सिस्टम
है ये मसाला फायरफॉक्स इस्तेमाल हो रहा है
ठीक है ना इस टाइप की इनफॉरमेशन देता है
इसका बहुत सर ये मतलब वेबसाइट का किस यूजर
दिखानी है अगर वो एंड्राइड
सिस्टम का उसे है ठीक है उसे तरह से चीज
चेंज करने के लिए उसे होता है ये लेकिन
इसको आप इस प्रूफ भी कर सकते हैं कस्टम भी
दे सकते हैं मतलब अलग-अलग रेजिडेंट देख के
ट्राई कर सकते हैं ठीक है उसके लिए
एक्सटेंशन आते हैं जैसे यहां पर एक है
हालांकि बहुत सारे एक्सटेंशन अलग-अलग आते
हैं तो यहां पे एक ऑलरेडी दिया हुआ है
उसको ट्राई कर लेते हैं
ठीक है इसको एड कर देते हैं यहां पे और
एक्सटेंशन जो है एड हो चुका है अब इसको
क्लोज करके मैं यहां पर वापस
ले जाते हैं और रिफ्रेश करते हैं ठीक है
अब देखिए अभी कोई भी रिक्वेस्ट आप देखेंगे
यहां पर आपका जो यहां पर ए रहा है इस
तरीके से आपका उसे रिजल्ट तो ये क्या है
इस टाइम फायरफॉक्स ठीक है अब इसको चेंज
करना है ट्राई करते हैं
करता हूं एप्पल वेब किट ठीक है
इसको अप्लाई कर देते हैं यहां पर अप्लाई
करना पड़ेगा अप्लाई कंटेनर ऑन विंडोज ठीक
है लाइक कंटेनर विंडोज कर देते हैं या
अप्लाई कंटिन्यू होल करेगा मेरे ख्याल से
लेकर ए रहा है अभी फेस करते हैं दिया है
यहां पर
देखते हैं हम लोग ये देखिए रिजल्ट क्रोम ए
रहा है ठीक है क्रोम
सिस्टम
जो है प्रूफ कर सकते हैं
पर यहां पर ये दिया हुआ है तो मैंने आपको
दिखा दिया और एक सबसे ज्यादा
ओपन कर सकते हैं
प्लेजर
का ठीक है
मतलब मैंने मां लीजिए
ए गया 24 अब ये क्या है इसमें करूंगा तो
बताया की ये क्या उसे कर रहा है मतलब
पॉसिबल है क्या क्या टेक्नोलॉजी उसे कर
रहा है उसके बड़े में आपको ये आइडिया देता
है जैसे यहां पर वर्डप्रेस उसे हो रहा है
यहां पर ये उसे हो रहा है ये रहा है ठीक
है लैंग्वेज के बड़े में बताया इसके बड़े
में बताया आपको क्वेश्चन पैटर्न कौन सा
आया करो पता कर सकता है तो मतलब कौन सा है
लैंग्वेज प्रोग्रामिंग देखिए पीएसपी ये
जितना डेटाबेस के बड़े में जितनी
इनफॉरमेशन मिल शक्ति है जितनी भी कलेक्ट
कर सकता है उतनी ये कलेक्ट करके आपको जो
है उसकी इनफॉरमेशन देता है ठीक है
ये चीज यहां पर इसको आप काफी उसे करेंगे
मतलब डेली लाइफ में अपने जो आपको ये साइड
पे बुटीक करने जाते हैं इंटरेस्टिंग करने
जाते हैं तो आप मुझे उसे तो करते ही करते
हैं क्योंकि आपको जरूरी हो रही है ठीक है
ना वो चीज यहां पे लिखी हुई है
यहां पर जो है वो ए जाएगा ठीक है
देखिए आप ट्रैक
ठीक है
एक्सटेंशन से मतलब टेक्नोलॉजी चेक कर सकते
हैं और यूजर एजेंट कर सकते हैं जो की
एनीमेशन में कम आएगा ठीक है ये डायरेक्टली
कॉन्फ्रेंस
जुड़ा हुआ है ठीक है
पर हाउस सिर्फ आपको पद्धति है बहुत सारे
कैसे आएगा प्रूफ करना पड़ेगा ठीक है कभी
छुपाने के लिए या कभी किसी और कम के लिए
आपको करना पड़ेगा तो वहां पे जरूर पड़ती
है इसकी भले यहां पे कौन सा कर रहे हैं
चेंज करना पद सकता है
जरूर पड़ेगी आपको इसका आंसर देख लेते हैं
चलिए तो आपका क्वेश्चन है वेबसाइट
बॉक्स और डी ब्राउज़र और डी कंप्यूटर ये
लिंक ओपन करनी है ब्राउज़र पे भी हो जाएगा
नॉर्मली ये ओपन कर लेते हैं फिर यूजिंग डी
डेवलपर टूल्स सिक्योरिटी टोटल नंबर ऑफ
क्वेश्चन ठीक है हमें डेवलपर टूल्स में
यहां पर मतलब इंस्पेक्टर जाना है
इसमें मैं बताना है टोटल कितने क्वेश्चन
यहां पर है ठीक है मतलब क्वेश्चन और आई
हुवे है ये क्वेश्चन
ये लड़का आंसर दे रहा है ठीक है तो एक
क्वेश्चन सामने है आपके इंस्पेक्टर
क्वेश्चन है इसमें टोटल ठीक है यहां पर
देख सकते हैं
एक बार
कंसोल टैबलेट
में आते हैं
सोर्सेस में इंडेक्स
ठीक है
तो
टोटल अकाउंट करेंगे तो 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
आएगा
ठीक है
मिल जाता है
पहले से कोई दिक्कत नहीं है
कुछ खास नहीं दिया हुआ है भाई मतलब है की
पिंक का इस्तेमाल आप करते हैं की जैसे चेक
करना हो की कोई सिस्टम चालू है या नहीं है
ठीक है जैसे आपको अभी टेस्ट में भी करते
हो मतलब इंटरनेट कनेक्टिविटी टेस्ट करनी
है ठीक है इस तरफ चीजों के लिए मतलब आपका
पिंक बस इतना करता है की सामने वाला जो
सिस्टम है वो चालू है की नहीं ये चेक करने
का में कम है पिंक में प्रपोज पी का यही
है जैसे मैं यहां पर विंडोज में आता हूं
और सिंपल लिखना हूं पिंक google.com
मुझे इस तरीके से रिस्पांस ए रहा है मैंने
पिंक पर रिस्पांस आया ठीक है चलिए यही
पिंग है
ठीक है जो ऐसी प्रोटोकॉल का इस्तेमाल करती
है
उसके बड़े में
आगे बढ़ते हैं
उसके लिए अलग-अलग होता है
की अगर आपने
गूगल सॉरी
दबाना पड़ेगा
अपने आप रुक जाएगा
8 पैकेट गए थे फिर मैंने कंट्रोल पर सीधा
दिया था ये अगर इस तरीके से आता है मतलब
कंट्रोल प्लस सीधा लगाया गया है पता ही
होगा आपको ये चीज तो चलिए
यह चीज विंडोज में करनी है ठीक है विंडोज
के लिए यहां पर पैकेट काउंट के लिए सेंड
कर सकते हैं आप यहां से चेक कर सकते हैं
तो ऐसे भी अब पिंक करके दास हेल्प कर
लीजिए विंडोज में और कंपेयर कर लीजिए क्या
चीज है यहां पर दास और होगा उसके लिए
अकाउंट पैकेट काउंट के लिए नंबर ऑफ यू को
रिक्वेस्ट है ठीक है अब एक रिक्वेस्ट मतलब
क्या है जो आप ऐसी एमपी रिक्वेस्ट भेजते
हैं उसको संप को रिक्वेस्ट किया जाता है
ठीक है और रिप्लाई आता है उसको रिप्लाई कर
जाता है ठीक है यहां पर तो हमें क्या करना
है यहां पर
पिंक किया ये ऑलरेडी करना है यहां पर दिखा
रहा है बस इसमें पी किया है इस तरीके से
रिस्पांस आया है ये वसल में
दिखा देता हूं आपको मैं अभी
जो हम यहां पर हमने कोई मशीन स्टार्ट किया
ना ये वाली ठीक है तो इसको मुझे पिंक करना
पड़ेगा वहां से अपनी अटैक बॉक्स है
क्योंकि मैं कनेक्ट
करता हूं
ठीक है
यहां पर ऊपर एग्जांपल दिया हुआ है उसके
बड़े में थोड़ी चीज बताई गई है की क्या
मतलब है डायरेक्टली ठीक है
ना ये टल वैल्यू आपको मिलेगी टाइम मिल रही
होगी टाइम मतलब कितने डर में रिप्लाई आया
है कितने मिली सेकंड में ठीक है और टल
यहां पर इसका मतलब होता है टाइम टेबल ये
काफी इंटरेस्टिंग कॉन्सेप्ट है इसके बड़े
में हम लोग तुरंत अभी नहीं समझेंगे
नेक्स्ट इसमें हम लोग ट्रेसर के बड़े में
पढ़ेंगे तब उनको समझेंगे उसको लेकिन इसको
नोटिस करके रखिएगा की कैपेसिटी वैल्यू
आपको मिल रही है ठीक है ये कुछ खास नहीं
है बाकी
आगे बढ़ते हैं वही चीज दी हुई है
यहां पर दिया हुआ है की पिंक का इस्तेमाल
अगर कोई होश रैचेबल है तो इस तरीके का
कवैरल मिलता है डेस्टिनेशन मतलब आपने ऐसा
कोई एपी दाल दिया जो अपने नेटवर्क में
नहीं है आपको उससे कनेक्ट नहीं कर सकते वो
सिस्टम में डॉ है ठीक है तो इस तरीके से
आपको जो है एरर मिलता है पिंकू भाई चेक
करने के लिए ऐसे कोई उसे करते हैं तो वो
भी वेरीफाई पहले पिंक करके चेक करता है एक
सिस्टम चालू है की नहीं ठीक है इसलिए कई
बार आपको सजेस्ट किया जाता है की जैसे
यहां पर दिया हुआ है ना दिया होगा मेरे
ख्याल से यहां
देखिए डी पर बाल
सिस्टम आईटी सेल्फ और अपने नेटवर्क
सर्च पैकेट ठीक है कई बार ऐसा होता है जो
वॉल होता है फायरवॉल जो है आपके सिस्टम
में ही हो या कोई एक्सटर्नल नेटवर्क
कर देता है और आपको रिप्लाई नहीं मिलता है
ठीक है तो ऐसे में आपको लगता है की जो
आपका सिस्टम है वो बैंड पड़ा हुआ है
सिस्टम बैंड नहीं पड़ा है ठीक है जैसे एम
एस मतलब विंडोज का जो फायरवॉल है टिंग को
ब्लॉक कर देता है और इसको आप ऐसे भी कर
सकते हैं अगर आपके यहां पर नेटवर्क
कंफीग्रेशन रहती है तो नेटवर्क के लिए
सिलेक्ट करेंगे प्रैक्टिस पे जाएंगे तो
सिलेक्ट कर सकते हैं की इसको प्राइवेट नेट
करना है पब्लिक नेटवर्क की तरह उसके लिए
अलग अलग हो सकते हैं ठीक है
वो ब्लॉक भी हो सकता है तो ऐसे में ये
मैंने जो बताया आपको स्कैन कर रहे होते
हैं विंडोज सिस्टम परमिशन कर रहे होते हैं
तो आप क्या करते हैं की आप एनएफसी करते
हैं वो आता है सिस्टम डॉ तो स्कैन नहीं
करता है ऐसे स्विच आता है ठीक है ऑलरेडी
क्रिकेट कितना बड़ा भेजना है कितनी सबसे
पहले आप सर्च कर सकते हैं तो लिस्ट से
होता है ये आंसर पहले हो चुका है कोई
दिक्कत नहीं है ठीक है
अब इसका उसे क्या है
अगर आप वो एक लिमिट से ऊपर का साइज का
भेजना है तो आप उसे कर सकते हैं इसके बड़े
में हम लोग अभी देख लेंगे और वही चीज है
की कर सकते हैं शायद अपने मां से ठीक है
एक रिक्वेस्ट आपको भेजनी है ये वाला
क्वेश्चन क्या है व्हाट इसे डी साइज ऑफ डी
एमपी हेडर इनसाइड
क्या है यहां पर देख लेते हैं कितना आता
है
जल्दी से
ऐसी चीजों में आपको जरूर नहीं है उसमें
ठीक है
फाइबर के बड़े में ठीक है और ये नई भी
करता था कोई कॉन्सेप्ट
सिस्टम ऑफलाइन नहीं होगा देखिए यहां पर
मैंने जरूरी है
इतना ये कमांड देनी है हमें इस रिपर्स को
पिंक करना है हमें 10 बार ठीक है हो में
रिप्लाई
यहां पर थिंक करना है बताना है की कितनी
रिप्लाई हमें आए हैं देखते हैं हम लोग
यहां पर ये काउंट भी आप क्लिक कर देता है
कितने रिप्लाई है
रिप्लाई मिले हैं और यही होना भी चाहिए
ठीक है चलिए अब ट्रेस रूट के बड़े में हम
बढ़ते हैं ट्रेंस रूट काफी एक इंटरेस्टिंग
चीज और कमल की है ठीक है
आपका एक तरीके से रूट जो होता है उसको
प्रेस करने के लिए कम आता है ये तो आपका
नाम समझ रहे होंगे खाने का मतलब क्या है
की अगर आपके सिस्टम को आपकी डिवाइस को
किसी दूसरे सिस्टम को रिलीज करना है तो
जरूरी है की तुम डायरेक्टली उसे कर ले वो
कई सिस्टम के थ्रू होते हुए जा सकता है
ठीक है ना तो जो बीच में जितने भी सिस्टम
राउटर चीज पढ़ेंगे ठीक है उन सबके आईपी
एड्रेस को आपको बताता है ये कौन ट्रेंस
रूट कमांड इनको ट्रैक करने का कम करता है
तो ये ट्रैक करने का कम कैसे करता है पहले
इसके लिए मैं कुछ एक दो टर्म से रूबरू
करता हूं पहले टर्म होप ठीक है हाउस मतलब
ही आते हैं ठीक है जो बीच में आपके पद रहा
है मतलब आपकी और टारगेट डिवाइस
नहीं है
तुम्हें ओपन करता हूं लीजिए विंडोज में
ठीक है
सॉरी
कम करते हैं हम लोग इसके लिए कोई हेल्प
होगा इसमें सेट करने के लिए
देख लेते हैं क्या है
ओके ठीक है
उसके बड़े में बता रहा है आपको तो उसको
पहले कंप्लीट होने देते हैं फिर आपको
दिखता हूं आगे मैं समझता हूं उसके बड़े
में
थोड़ा लंबा होने वाला है
आपको समझिए कैसे हो रहा है मुझे पैकेट है
वह इससे होते हुए इस पर जा रहा है फर्स्ट
सेकंड थर्ड पर ऐसे करके नीचे दिया जाएगा
फाइनल आप देखेंगे की डेस्टिनेशन पे हो
जाएगा और डेस्टिनेशन आईपी क्या है ये ठीक
है तो ये देखते रहेंगे फाइनली अपने
डेस्टिनेशन में प्रोपोस्टा है प्रारंभित
करते हैं हम लोग अभी तो हो रहा है
इसके आउटपुट को हम लोग पुरी तरीके से लाइक
करेंगे ठीक है आपको समझ में ए रहा है की
ये तीन तो टाइम क्या दिया हुआ है स्टार
क्या ए रहा है जो नीचे ए रहा है अभी तो
समझेंगे इसको ठीक है ये वही चीज है मतलब
कैसे दूर जा रहा है बीच में पद रहा है ठीक
है इसको पूरा करते हैं तुमको समझता हूं
डिटेल क्या होता है यहां पर डिटेल का
इस्तेमाल होता है बेसिकली ये डायग्राम
का फूल फॉर्म होता है टाइम तू लीव ठीक है
अब ये सुनने में तो कोई ग रहा है की टाइम
के बड़े में बता रहा होगा लेकिन ये टाइम
करो नहीं बता रहा है बेसिकली ये एक वैल्यू
है की कितने
डॉक्टर के बीच से आपका जो है पैकेट वो जा
सकता है ड्रॉप होने से पहले यानी मतलब
क्या है मतलब ये की मां लीजिए आपका डिवाइस
यही है और आपको डिवाइस अभी तक उसे करना
ठीक है
आपका यहां पर आपको डिवाइस बी को उसे करना
है
पहले आपके पास एक दो तीन कर और पांच पांच
आउटर बीच में पद रहा है ठीक है मतलब
डिवाइस ए से पैकेट निकलेगा वन पे जाएगा
फिर तू जाएगा फिर थ्री पे जाएगा फोर हो
जाएगा 5 ए जाएगा और फिर बी पे जाएगा ठीक
है अब टल वैल्यू कहां-कहां आई है जब ये
कोई पैकेट भेजेगा तो एक टल सेट करके
भेजेगा मां लीजिए आते ठीक है अब क्या होगा
जब टल वही जब टल वैल्यू जो है उसको मैं एक
और स्पेस देता हूं
और जब ये राउटर बन के पास पहुंच ठीक है
अच्छे से चलिए डॉक्टर वन के पास हो जाता
है ठीक है तो टीटू की वैल्यू एक घाट जाएगी
इसने एक कम किया ठीक है मतलब यहां से यह
पूछा इसके बाद तो इसके पास एड है एक तरीके
से खाने मतलब इसके पास 80 था ठीक है
इसीलिए उसको सेवन कर दिया ठीक है तू तू के
पास क्या पूछा 7 पूछा तो तूने उसको सिक्स
कर दिया ठीक है थ्री के पास क्या बच्चा 6
हो जाति है
फाइव कर दिया फोर के पास फाइव हो जाएगा
इसमें क्या उसको कर दिया फोर कर दिया और
फाइव के पास क्या पूछा 450 क्या कर दिया
थ्री कर दिया ठीक है और ये थ्री जब इसने
कर दिया करके इसके आगे भेजो तो बी के पास
क्या पहुंचाओ बी के पास पहुंच 3 ठीक है तो
बी उसको तू करें चैनल को नहीं पता क्योंकि
डेस्टिनेशन है ठीक है तो गैस पैकेट फोर्स
गया मतलब हर एक राउटर जो बीच में पड़ा
उसने टल को एक-एक कम करते गया ठीक है अब
यहां पर इससे फायदा क्या होगा इससे फायदा
ये हुआ अगर अगर आते ना हो के वैल्यू होती
है आपकी फोर ठीक है
अब क्या होती 4 तो यहां पर क्या होता है
कौन से बादल जाता है कैसे खत्म
वन क्या करता है उसको थ्री कर देता ठीक है
भेजना के लिए तो वन के पास तो फिर राहत है
ठीक है तू के पास क्या राहत है थ्री राहत
इसके पास क्या था तू राहत था इसके अंदर वन
राहत और इसके पास क्या राहत है इसके पास
जब वो आता है तो फाइनली वो जीरो हो जाता
ठीक है
जीरो हो गया था और जब वो जीरो हो गया तो
पैकेट वहीं पे ड्रॉप हो जाएगा क्योंकि ये
डेस्टिनेशन नहीं है ठीक है अगर जीरो हो
गया डेस्टिनेशन में नहीं पहुंच तो पैकेट
वहीं पर ड्रॉप हो जाएगा और यहां से ये
वाला डिवाइस आपको एक को आपकी डिवाइस ए को
यानी ओरिजिनल सोर्स को एक वो भेजेगा क्या
नाम है एक रिप्लाई भेजिएगा ठीक है बताते
हुए की जो है दिक्कत हो गई है और पैकेट जो
है छोड़ दिया गया है ड्रॉप कर दिया गया है
ठीक है ट्रांसलेट करके एरर कहते हैं ऐसे
कुछ लिख लेते हैं नाम से कुछ नहीं दे दिया
होगा
चलिए देख लेंगे वो चीज तो वही मतलब है ये
आपको इस तरीके से कम करता है जैसे दिखता
हूं मैं
64 था ठीक है यहां सेंड हुआ
63 हो गया
61 हो गया ठीक है इस तरीके से एक-एक राहत
है अब क्या हुआ है जीरो आईटी बिल बी ड्रॉप
ठीक है
यहां पर ए जाएगा
अब इसका इस्तेमाल कैसे होता है ट्रेस रूट
में ट्रेस रूट
किया था और फाइनल हमने वहां तक पहुंच गए
ठीक है ये बीच में सर उठ रहा है ठीक है और
उसका मतलब है तो मैं क्या करके आपको इसने
क्या किया इसने पहले सबसे पहले क्या किया
ट्रेंस रूट की वैल्यू ही बनते कर दी ठीक
है यहां पर ये इसका आउटपुट देखेंगे इसको
भी इसका क्या करें फ्रूट की वैल्यू हम वन
सेट कर दें तो क्या होगा पहले अगर ड्रेस
की वैल्यू जब वो दूसरे टेस्ट में जाएगा
जीरो हो जाएगा ठीक है तो अगर वो
डेस्टिनेशन हो जाएगा तो वो रिस्पांस करेगा
तो पहले पहले
मिल गया फिर हम टल तू करके भेज देंगे अब
पहले वाला आप नहीं करेगा दूसरा को ड्रॉप
कर देगा तो दूसरे वाले पे हमें इस तरह मिल
गया फिर हम डिटेल फूल कर देंगे अब तीसरा
टॉप कर देगा तीसरी टाइप मिल गया क्योंकि
जो भी ड्रॉप करेगा
यही कम यहां पर हो रहा है वन सेट किया
इसका रिस्पांस मिला आईटी तू सेट किया इसका
रिस्पांस मिला 3 4 5 6 7 ऐसे करके हमने
बनाते गए ठीक है तो बनाते गए जब तक हमने
फाइनल डेस्टिनेशन हमारी विच नहीं हो गई इस
तरीके से हमें बीच की साइड डिवाइस का जो
है पता मिल गया अब इनका क्या मतलब है ये
तीन तो यहां पर टाइम दिया हुआ है ये इधर
ये जो नीचे है ये 1234 ये तो हाफ नंबर है
ठीक है ये हर एक रिक्वेस्ट में तीन तीन
पैकेट भेजता है ठीक है ना हर एक रिक्वेस्ट
में तीन तीन पैकेट भेजो है भेजता है इसका
रीजन ये है की कभी-कभी दिक्कत हो जाए ठीक
है और आपको एवरेज टाइम कैलकुलेट करना है
उसके लिए ये तीन पैकेट भेजता है ठीक है
तीन बार ट्राई करता है मतलब एक हफ्ते में
तीन टाइटंस हैं तो ये पहले पैकेट का टाइम
है दूसरे का टाइम है और तीसरी पे टाइम है
ठीक है राउंड ट्रिप ट्रेन तो ये वही चीज
है तीन टाइटंस मिल रहा है ठीक है ये स्टार
क्या होता है अब ये स्टार का मतलब है की
यहां पे कुछ दिक्कत हुई है की आपको ये
टाइम नहीं है ठीक है ना वो तो आपका
कभी-कभी एक ही स्टार है दो स्टार ए रहा है
तीनों पे ना आए मतलब एक बार ए गया दो बार
कम नहीं किया ठीक है अगर तीनों स्टार है
मतलब और यहां पर रिक्वेस्ट आपको नहीं मिला
बीच में यहां पे एक हाफ ओवर स्काइप को
नहीं मिला तो ऐसा तब होता है ठीक है जब
आपका कई बार ऐसा होता है की वीडियो सेट
होता है की अगर आपका यहां पे कोई पैकेट
ड्रॉप हो रहा है तो फॉर्मल को ऐसे हो चाहे
जैसे भी हो उसको रिस्पांस करना ही माना है
खाने का मतलब डिजीजर क्या गया है की भाई
तुम पर रिस्पांस नहीं करना है ठीक है तो
इस कैसे में वह ट्रेसशूट से बैक जाएगा या
फिर का रहा है की रिस्पांस ही नहीं दिया
गया ठीक है तो ये बताया कैसे आपको यदि
आपको समझ में कितनी है इसमें जो एक्सरसाइज
में रिस्पांस नहीं दिया ठीक है तो ऐसा भी
किया था सबको एनकाउंटर हो सकता है लेकिन
अगर उसके बाद एकदम रुक जाए इसका मतलब कम
ही नहीं हो रहा है आपका डेस्टिनेशन पहुंची
नहीं है रीचेबल नहीं है लेकिन इसके बाद
आपका कम हुआ आगे का ठीक है इसका मतलब
रजिस्ट्रेशन थी तो डेस्टिनेशन अप्लाई
करेगा ही ना डेस्टिनेशन को एरर रिपोर्ट
नहीं करना है डेस्टिनेशन तो बताना है की
मेरे को पैकेट मिल गया ठीक है तो वो तो
रिप्लाई जो है आएगा ही आएगा
चलिए आगे बढ़ते हैं
या फिर ये दिया हुआ है की लाइनेक्स में जो
है ये ड्रेस का वो आपका उसे करता है ठीक
है और वही चीज जो आपका विंडोज में है वो
आपका उसे करता है ठीक है ना चलिए आगे
बढ़ते हैं
कोई सिंपल सा आईपी एड्रेस चली यही कर देता
हूं मैं अपनी सेट कर लेते हैं
मैं भी आपको चीटियां से खेल के दिखाऊंगा
अच्छे से
इसको देते हैं पहले
स्टार्टिंग
ट्राई कर लीजिए
ग आपका
रिस्पांस वही रहेगा यहां पर रिस्पांस टाइम
भी दिया हुआ है ठीक है वही चीज है वही
इनफॉरमेशन है ठीक है अभी टाइम तीन टाइम
दिए हुए हैं और भाई मतलब है अभी कुछ नया
उसमें नहीं है ठीक है कमान की वर्किंग और
चीज़ से ही रहेंगे कॉन्सेप्ट से ही रहेगा
ठीक है और एक इंपॉर्टेंट बात की जरूरी
नहीं है की हर बार पास आपका से ही हो पास
आपका चेंज होता राहत है बिल्कुल चेंज हो
सकता है ठीक है जिसमें आपको कुछ नहीं है
की पास जो है दिक्कत हो रहा है ठीक है
आपका हर बार से ही रिस्पांस आया है पास
आपका पासवर्ड आपका चेंज हो सकता है ठीक है
यहां पर
आपको
आईपी क्या है और टाइम क्या है सर्च यहां
पर आपको दी हुई है इस टाइप मतलब यहां पे
वही से चीज है मतलब वहां पे था ठीक है ये
भी आपको तीन पैकेट जो है भेजकर ट्राई कर
रहा है बार-बार ठीक है ना चलिए
क्वेश्चन देख लेते हैं यहां पर पहले
क्वेश्चन हमारा इंटरेस्ट रूट ए व्हाट इसे
डी आईपीएल एड्रेस ऑफ डी लास्ट आउट हो
लास्ट आउटर देखना है हमें ये ड्रेस रूट ए
है ठीक है इसमें दो बार ट्रेंस रूट किया
है चलाया है और दिखाए की दोनों अलग-अलग
पास हुआ है ठीक है फॉलो हमेशा इसमें जरूरी
है आपके लिए
आपका ये वाला आईपी एड्रेस
कर देता हूं
ठीक है
रन ट्रेसर कितना ठीक है
कितने सारे बीच में है
यहां पर
मतलब
क्या होता है
सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट कॉन्सेप्ट यहां पे वही था
ठीक है क्योंकि
जरूर नहीं पड़ेगी जब आप नेटवर्क पेन टेस्ट
कर रहे होंगे तब आपको जरूर पद शक्ति है
हमारा ठीक है जो भी तरीका है वो एक्टिव है
एक्टिवली हम लोग जो है इनफॉरमेशन को बेहतर
कर रहे हैं
ठीक है
जिसमें आप कस्टम टल वैल्यू कर सकते हैं
कॉम को पिंक करता हूं
तीनों पर गया ठीक है मतलब को कम से कम
चारों पर ए गया मतलब कम से कम कर डिटेल
नहीं पड़ेगी ठीक है ना
चलिए
दिखाऊंगा
बढ़िया से पिंग हो रहा है ठीक है अब मैं
इसको रॉक देता हूं ठीक है रॉक कर क्या
करूंगा यहां पर डिटेल वैल्यू को चेंज
करूंगा दास आई और यहां पर 10 दे देता हूं
मां लीजिए अभी तो क करना चाहिए मेंटर करता
हूं क्योंकि जस्ट बहुत है ठीक है मेरे
ख्याल से 10 चेहरा तो नहीं है उसमें अगर
जैसे होगा तो फिर टाइम हो जाएगा क्योंकि
टाइम आउट हो ही गया ये ऑलरेडी
इसको बनाते हैं डिटेल वैल्यू को इसको मैं
30 कर देता हूं अभी बढ़िया स्प्रिंग होगा
देखिए
वैल्यू कम पद जा रही है 10 वैल्यू है 10
से वहां पे सवाल हो रहा है ठीक है 10 का
11 करता हूं मैं
ठीक है
यहां पर आपको आईपी एड्रेस मिल रहा है की
कहां से वापस आया पैकेट ये कई 11वां पे है
ठीक है इसमें 12 कर देता हूं
तेरे कर देते हैं हम लोग
इस तरीके से आप जो है कर सकते हैं पता ठीक
है ये आपको समझा करो कैसे हो रहा है और जो
रिस्पांस ए रहा है ये होता है अगर आपने
कस्टम डिटेल दिया हुआ है तो ये रिस्पांस
कर देती है ठीक है जो वहां से ए रहा है
ताकि आप तक पहुंच सके ये आपको डिटेल नहीं
है जो रिस्पांस आया है उसने भी तो कोई
डीटेल्स किया होगा हर पैकेट राहत है अगर
नहीं सेट रहेगा तो पैकेट इंफिनिटी
इंटरेक्ट तो घूमते रहेंगे ठीक है कभी ना
कभी खत्म होना है तो कहां खत्म हो रहा है
ठीक है इसीलिए इसका नाम है टाइम तू लीव
भले ही ये राखी टाइम पे नहीं पता था टाइम
चीज के बड़े में लेकिन इस तरीके से
रिलेटेड है इसीलिए यहां पर 51 ये इसी लिए
लिखा है तो इससे कंफ्यूज नहीं होना है ठीक
है ना समझ में आएगा आपको ये थोड़ा
डायरेक्टली इसको फिर ट्राई कीजिएगा
उसको प्रेस नोट को ठीक है
कहां से ए गया ये सब मतलब
करने के लिए कर सकते हैं
कनेक्ट करें एक सिंपल सा मतलब क्योंकि
ऑथेंटिकेशन
के लिए भी हम लोग चैनल का स्वागत है जैसे
हम जीडीपी के लिए कर रहे हैं ठीक है जो
करके दिखता हूं मेरे यहां पर वेएसएसएल में
टॉयलेट ऑलरेडी इंस्टॉल्ड है
ठीक है तो मैं क्या करूंगा तेल नेट से
कनेक्ट करूंगा मैरिज में google.com
कनेक्ट करना चाहता हूं आपको आईपी लिखना है
आपको पॉड लिखना है 10 मिनट पे चाय पी या
ह्यूस्टन जो भी लिख सकते हैं मुझे कनेक्ट
करना है तो यहां पर अब ये वेट कर रहा है
मेरे इनपुट के लिए तो एचटीटीपी का जो
बेसिक एक ही स्ट्रक्चर होता है ठीक है
रिक्वेस्ट का वो इस तरीके से शुरू होता है
ठीक है ना की आपको गेट रिक्वेस्ट करनी है
एस/ओ डायरेक्टरी होम पेज जो भी हो एचडी भी
1.1 से ठीक है याद रखना जब मैंने आपको
यहां पर रन करके दिखाए था फिर करके दिखा
देता हूं मैंने आपको कहा था की इसको देख
लीजिए मैं अभी उसे करूंगा इसको तो मैंने
इसी समय के लिए बोला था उसको क्योंकि यहां
पर
कोई लोकल होस्ट थाउजेंड मतलब 48000 एक्सेस
करता है तो मुझे यहां पर जो डॉग्स मिलेंगे
ठीक है इसमें देख सकते हैं की रिक्वेस्ट
क्या की गई है गेट होम पेज 1.1 ठीक है ये
रिक्वेस्ट की गई है और 200 रिस्पांस रहा
है इसका तो रिक्वेस्ट ही नहीं है ठीक है
इसको हम लोग डायरेक्टली भेज सकते हैं तो
हमें क्या मिलेगा होम पेज जो भी होगा तो
मैं गूगल का होम पेज लेट हूं ठीक है तो
मैं क्या करूंगा मैं लिखूंगा गेट
स्लैश जीडीपी / 1.1 ठीक है अब यहां पे
आपको जो भी अपना एक घंटा करके आप यहां पर
और लिख सकते हैं जैसे आप लिख दीजिए होस्ट
ठीक है google.com जो भी चाहिए देख सकते
हैं हेडर और सर हीटर देने के बाद आपको डबल
इंटर करना है ठीक है डबल इंटर तो आपका
रिक्वेस्ट भेज दिया जाएगा क्योंकि
रिस्पांस आया है ठीक है चूंकि यहां पर
मैंने ज्यादा कुछ नहीं दिया है मतलब
रिसेंट कीजिए इसके साथ ट्राई कर रहा हूं
इसलिए यहां पर पूरा रिस्पांस जो हमारा
नहीं आया है ठीक है ना क्योंकि तुम उसको
मैं चलिए
इसी ट्राई करते हैं अभी
देखिए यहां पर इस तरीके से रिस्पांस ए गया
है ठीक है बेड रेस्ट हो गई यहां पर दोबारा
करते हैं इसको
यहां पर
कुछ बेसिक
फ्लेयर में आपको इनफॉरमेशन मिल गई अगर
आपको सर्वर कौन सी चीज है इनफॉरमेशन मिल
जाएगी ठीक है ये बेसिक कम होता है
मतलब जो है बैनर के ही कम आता है में ठीक
है इसे मैं कनेक्ट करके यह तो मैं ऐसे
रिपोर्टेड भी नहीं कर रहा हूं आपको यहां
पर मिल जाएगा फिर ठीक है और इस तरीके से
आपको सर्विस इनफॉरमेशन मिल शक्ति है इसमें
ठीक है की भाई कम करता है अब इसको अलग-अलग
ट्राई कर सकते हैं ठीक है जहां भी ये क कर
रहा हूं 10 मिनट को ठीक है तो आप इंटरनेट
भी चेक कर सकते हैं जिससे मेरा पोर्टेबल
से मैंने करके दिखा रहा है आपको पहले ठीक
है तो वही चीज है तो बहन के पास इस्तेमाल
कर सकते हैं ठीक है ना वही करके इसका
एड्रेस को देखने में मैंने रिंग में चलिए
क्लोज कर देता हूं मैं अभी के लिए
ओके तो टैलेंट को वही एग्जांपल है यहां पे
वही चीज हुई है कुछ खास नहीं है
पोस्ट भेजो है यहां पर भेजिए ठीक है चलिए
यहां पर इनको एक रिस्पांस मिल गया इंजन
इसका कलर का वर्जन ठीक है इस तरीके से
वर्जन मिल सकते हैं तो ये सब कम होता है
इसका तो एक्टिवली इस तरीके से हम रिकॉर्ड
कर सकते हैं तेलनेट का इस्तेमाल करके ठीक
है क्वेश्चन देख लेते हैं क्या है स्टार्ट
तो है ठीक है हमें
कनेक्ट हो गया हमारा गेट रिक्वेस्ट भेजनी
है
ये ए गया है
कॉपी कर लेते हैं यही आंसर देना है
नाम बताना
यहां पर
चलिए यह हो गया
उसे करने
कर सकता है
का मतलब क्या है की इससे आप कनेक्शन भेज
भी सकते हैं
बहुत बार ऐसा होता है आपका मैक्सिमम टाइम
जब आपको ईपीएफ के अंदर होते हैं आपको
रिवर्स कनेक्शन देना होता है तब नेट
कैटिगरी लेते हैं ठीक है
तो उसका कनेक्शन दिया आपने ले सकते हैं
ठीक है चलिए इसके बड़े में हम लोग डिटेल
में बाद में देखेंगे लेकिन अभी वैसे ही
दिखाऊंगा मैं आपको ठीक है जैसे यहां पर
कनेक्शन के बड़े में दिया हुआ है की आप
मां लीजिए मैं ओपन करता हूं यहां पर
ये 10 मिनट मेरे ऑलरेडी इंस्टॉल है इसमें
लिख देता हूं मैं लीजिए ट्राई एक मी
डॉट कॉम गेट
यहां पे वही कम कर रहा हूं
ठीक है
दास व्यूवर्स आउटपुट इसको लिख सकते हैं आप
दास और एलपी और दास वे एन एलजी करके देख
सकते हैं तो मेरा करने वाला हूं यहां पर
मैं यहां पर काली दोबारा ओपन करूंगा ठीक
है एवल है दो अलग-अलग टाइम में इसको ओपन
कर लूंगा ठीक है यहां से मैं सर्वर चालू
करूंगा नेट ठीक है एन वे ल पी पोर्ट फोर
फोर मां लीजिए ठीक है देखिए लिसनिंग ऑन
अन्य फोर मतलब किसी भी इसमें किसी भी आएगी
ठीक है ये आईपीएल विजय कुछ भी लिख दीजिए
अब मैं यहां से कुछ भेजता हूं मां लीजिए
मैं गेट रिक्वेस्ट भेजूंगा कुछ भेजूं ठीक
है ये आगे आईटी इसे वहां जाएगी चूंकि ये
कोई सर्वर तो है नहीं जो रिस्पांस करेगा
तो ये रिस्पांस नहीं करेगा इसमें ये भेजो
देखिए जो मैंने यहां भेजो वो यहां भी ए
गया अब यहां पे आप हाय हेलो कुछ भी लिखिए
जो यहां लिखेंगे वो वहां जाएगा जो वहां
लिखेंगे वहां जाएगा ठीक है एकदम चाट अप की
तरह चाट एप्लीकेशन की तरफ ठीक है तो ये भी
अगर सर्वर यहां पे अगर आपने सेट किया होता
तो क करता है ठीक है तो ये वही चीज है
मतलब आपका यहां से इनविटेशन हो सकता है ये
इसीलिए मैंने कहा दिखाए की बगैर ऐसा होगा
की रिवर्सल लेंगे थ्रू अगर आप कमेंट
भेजेंगे भाई तो अभी चाहिए नॉर्मल ठीक है
यहां से आएगी लेकिन कराएंगे आगे ठीक है हम
किसी त्रिभुज को सेंड करेंगे तो वो भी हम
लोग देखेंगे आगे ठीक है फिलहाल ये बेसिक
चीज थी
इसलिए कुछ खास नहीं दिया हुआ है इस के
बड़े में पूरा दिया हुआ है
टेक बॉक्स ओपन
सॉरी
इंपॉर्टेंट
करना चाहिए
देख लेते हैं क्या दिक्कत ए रही है इसमें
चालू करना पड़ेगा
कोई दिक्कत नहीं है ठीक है आराम से गूगल
आराम से इसको आईपी एड्रेस आने का वेट करते
हैं तब
ठीक है
उसका वीडियो जल्दी से तब तक
हो रहा है
यहां पर अलग मशीन थी ठीक है यहां पे अलग
मशीन थी और यहां पर अलग मशीन है ठीक है
जिसमें
स्किपिंग ही नहीं होगा इसीलिए हमारी
दिक्कत होती है ठीक है ना था|
क्वेश्चन वीडियो अमेरिका से 6.40
.17 ठीक है
यहां पर सारे कमेंट दिए हुए हैं और आपको
समझ में आएगा क्या मतलब है
तो ये यूटिलिटी वही यूटिलिटी है जो डेली
लाइफ ठीक है सब को उसे करता है थिंक सबको
उसे करता है और यूनाइटेड भी अपने दोस्तों
अगर सिक्योरिटी में आपने उसे किया ही
होंगे ठीक है तो वो कैसे कम कर रहा है
उसको अच्छे से मैंने जरूरी होता है ठीक है
ना वो इंपॉर्टेंट चीज है ठीक है ये सब
कैसे कम कर रहा है तो ये आपका समझ में
नेक्स्ट लेक्चर में हम लोग कुछ और दिखने
वाले हैं जैसे की सेल कैसे कम करते हैं
रिवर्सल क्या होता है ठीक है
सेल्फ के साथ-साथ हम ये भी समझेंगे की नेट
कैट के थ्रू ये सब कैसे लेने हैं ठीक है
ये सब भी हम समझेंगे ठीक है तो आज के
लेक्चर में अभी जॉइन करता हूं मैं यही पे
ठीक है नेक्स्ट मिलेगी लेकिन उससे पहले
आपको साइट ऑफ कंप्लीट कर लेना है और यहां
से इस बार यदि आपको करना है हमारे फेस को
आपको सर्च करना है डिशुनी से अकादमी ठीक
है डायरेक्टली आपको मिल जाएगा यहां पर
सॉरी
कर लीजिएगा और पोस्ट में आपको जो है कमेंट
जरूर करना है की आपने क्या शिखा की आपको
अच्छा लगा और क्या अभी जो भी आपका रिव्यू
है उसके बड़े में आपको लिख देना है ठीक है
तारा का जरूर कीजिएगा ट्री एक मेरी भी अगर
आपने कंप्लीट किया साथ में तो शेर कर
दीजिए उसको यहां पर से कंप्लीट कर देते
हैं हम लोग अभी चेक कर दीजिए अगर आप कर
सकते हैं तो ये जो फ्री हूं मैं ठीक है और
मैं टैग कर दीजिएगा ठीक है ना तो आज ट्राई
करते हैं नेक्स्ट लेक्चर
ठीक है थैंक्स पर वॉच